foreign
Oklahoma and talk to Deidre what's up
Deidre
Hi how are you partying how about you
I'm good awesome what's up
um yes I have a question I am
examination when I had my daughter okay
and she is six years old and since she
was about four years old
she
keeps she knows we're open about how she
was conceived and everything but
she tells a lot of people
I don't have a dad
like random people
um she almost feel like she mom shames
me about it and I tried to explain to
her about families come in all different
shapes and sizes and I had you on
purpose this way
and uh she just she just doesn't get it
and I don't know I don't really know how
to handle it can I ask you some hard
questions yeah promise
yeah we're friends okay
um Are you ashamed of it
no no I I think it's really neat I'm
proud of it why would you care in the
world what a five or six year old has to
say
I just
um maybe not so much shame but you know
you see
you hear about the stigmas of how kids
are raised by you know just a mom and
you know they I don't want to feel like
she's missing out on anything but
um but she is I mean she's missing out
on a dad right
yeah so there is like you don't want
that but there is and I think you can
make a great home in life for her
yes but also it's it's like a uh it's
it's a both in or an either or right
yeah so I think there's some
truth to that what what
here's the hard the hard
reality
is she does have a biological father
somewhere
yes and he was in it I picked an open
donor okay and she knows that when she's
18. okay she's allowed to pursue it
awesome okay is that person interested
in that Pursuit when they're 18.
I don't know it's it was through a sperm
bank and I think basically all they do
is just hand them paperwork of what they
have
you know and it's up to you which I will
do whatever she wants sure
but I try to also she's got and we're
friends on like Facebook we have a
private Facebook with the other moms and
I think you got 23 other half siblings
that
you know none of them have a dad and
they're all doing good
allegedly
and please don't put that on her
no because the way you're saying that is
there's 22 other ones that are doing
great and you're the Oddball here and I
don't think that's accurate yeah yeah
that's true
um every one of those kids is going to
wonder who am I
and every one of those kids is gonna
wonder where am I from
and every one of those kids is going to
wonder
the question that all children ask which
is
why didn't dad want me and they don't
understand the complexity of of modern
science and technology and the abilities
that we all have now and so those
questions are going to remain and I
think the challenge is not to squash
those questions or to beat them out of a
kid not not literally but figuratively
and to truly honor those questions
because they're existential
right I mean they're they're spiritual
in a way they're they're woven into us
right
and so I think it's providing a context
for
safety to ask any and all questions and
I also think it's very important to have
conversations about there are private
conversations
there are private things that we talk
about mother and daughter that are not
to be shared with other adults
and she chooses to share those things
and she is choosing to opt out of
something that some sort of thing that
she loves like accountability
is that does that make sense
yes I just didn't I didn't understand
I'm I
so do you understand how how but
let me see it like this
she sees a mom who's incredibly open
talks about anything with a six-year-old
which I think you should be pretty
careful
um there's a difference between openness
and over sharing right my friend Rachel
Cruz says share don't scare there's a
sense of and I think you you nailed it
on the head I picked you of all the kids
in the world I chose you like those
those are that's really important
language
um but you can understand that what she
sees such an open mom talking about
anything and everything and there's no
shame and let's talk about it all that
then all of a sudden there's just some
other adults that she likes and that you
seem to like that she she starts having
the conversation and it's like Sean what
are you doing
in a six-year-old that's a hard toggle
for a four five and six year old
learning the social nuance and what's
cool and what's not cool and here's my
concern my concern is she sees you wins
or she feels your attention or
anxiousness and she will then make that
a problem that she has to solve and that
that's why I asked you the first
question I asked you is Are you ashamed
of this or are you questioning your
choice because
she's gonna absorb that and that
questioning is going to come off as
she's questioning me
see what I'm saying yeah it's more of
how she says it to people it's a it's
like a pity for her I'm the only I'm the
only one who doesn't have a dad no
you're not there are a lot of kids out
there who don't have dads there's a lot
of kids that do have dads that don't
want anything to do with them right yeah
but but she's six and that's hard that's
a hard thing to process for
six-year-olds
and in her world you and I can tell the
difference between hey that that lady's
just on boyfriend number four and that
guy's on wife number five for her all
her friends have dads
yeah there's a there's a paternal figure
and when you and I even both know all
her friends that's not even true
right but in her six or seven-year-old
little mind it is
yeah and so one of the questions that
young children are constantly asking and
this is a an unconscious question do I
belong do I belong do I belong do I
belong do I belong
and some kids when they feel like they
don't belong they shut the system down
other kids when they feel like they
don't belong they race out to pull the
bullets out of everybody else's gun it
becomes a tool right okay and so you
just have a daughter who's learning from
her mom that and talk about anything
whenever we want and yeah she's
probably doing what my daughter did and
weaponizing that a bit and if she can
get some pity then adults will bend down
and look her in the eye and talk to her
in a quieter voice and say oh but you're
loved and that gives her exactly what
she's looking for so the goal as a
parent is not to shut the questions down
it's to give her those things in other
areas so that she doesn't have to go
searching for it here
yes does that make sense yeah
um does she understand the difference
between private conversations and not
we're working on it okay so I sometimes
have to have to explain to her that you
know things we talk about you know not
all not all people you know at her age
are going to understand and talk about
so don't go sharing with your friends
everything well and and so I remember
one time my son he's probably eight or
nine he said something or did something
and we got in my truck and I looked at
him and said dude will you just be cool
and I could tell on his face I remember
laughing like he has no idea what the
phrase do will you just be cool means he
did not know what that meant and if I
looked at one of my grown-up buddies who
had said the exact thing and said do we
be cool they would have known yeah I
probably shouldn't have said that and so
I had to be very explicit
so if we talk about something if she
asks a question like
Mommy why don't I have a daddy and
you've answered that question 500 times
yes
um you can go with the answer that
you've given her that's age appropriate
that's not some big over explanation or
some under explanation or some
dishonesty but like a a good
straightforward here's the answer it
followed by
and this is a private conversation
between Mom and the little girl that she
loves more than anything
okay what does Private mean
and so my kids know the difference
between secrets and private things
and private is also a word we use for
bathing suit covering areas of our
bodies like what is okay and what's not
okay and what's okay to be seen what's
okay for touch all that kind of stuff we
have that conversation so the word
private means not embarrassed or shame
private means incredibly special
okay does that make sense and so yeah
private means something that like I'm
gonna like this is for me you see what
I'm saying and not in a nobody can see
this because it's shameful or gross no
opposite
okay okay that makes sense okay yes um
yes it does but I I want to go back to
the very beginning
I want you to make peace with the world
that you've created
yes are you at peace with it
of how I decided to have her on my own
no I I'm 100 confident there
that's I'm getting the sense and tell me
I'm off because I can be way out to
lunch here
I'm getting the sense that either it's
more difficult or you're anticipating
these questions or the explanations
aren't working it's just different than
you felt or thought or or hoped for
I didn't think it would happen this soon
okay kind of things happen when they're
like 13.
oh man okay that's very smart for her
age and talks like a little adult and
takes things in like well don't let me
do this because it's just me and her but
when she was like four and she started
asking kind of questions I'm like okay
where's the book for this and you know
because this is a simple I mean this is
a unique situation not everyone in
Shawnee you know has done this
I can imagine that number is very small
um yes but uh there is a couple of great
books I don't have them off top of my
head um on Amazon that you can find in
that are just good reading books
um that walk through this
um and it may be great if you can maybe
these Facebook groups can help if you
can find
somebody who's a teenager or an adult
who was conceived this way that would be
able to talk to your daughter and in
some sort of high level
relationship kind of way it might be
good to have some like a light out ahead
of this path here for her okay and it
might be good for you to have some
parents down the road have you spent
some time with them
um other women have done this
um yeah some of them are they're a
little on the the far end
the side almost like man haters a lot of
times yeah and so it's kind of hard to
find one that you know just did this
because it was her time and just didn't
have the best relationships to wait for
the right one gotcha so I think I think
it's worthy of finding one or two
mentors that you can have on text thread
that you can text and be like whoa my
eight-year-old just asked this and
they'll be like yeah it's gonna be weird
um I think that's super super valuable
for you
okay yes let me give you one last little
tidbit she can never become your best
friend
okay she can't carry the weight of the
adult decisions that you have made and
have to make moving forward
right 25 is the cut off that I give
folks
okay 21 you can take your kid to get a
tattoo and a drink that's fine oh that's
fine 25 is when you can transition like
now we're we're peers we're buddies and
there's still that weird like we're not
gonna talk about sex we're gonna talk
about some of that stuff but we can we
can talk about a lot more in a friend
kind of way but man she can't handle
that that weight of that relationship
she needs to see her mom have grown-up
mom friends
okay that's a really important gift for
her
but let her ask all questions they're
all okay and they're all worthy and
they're all good let's work really hard
on Upstream where are moments that you
are putting your hands on her face
during a day hopefully every day yes
there are moments when you're getting
down on eye level and or getting down on
all fours and just you're playing Wolf
Pack 2 or whatever weird thing she's
imagining or when there's no talking and
she's just tired and you'll just color
together next to each other
where are those moments constantly
popping up popping up and they're going
to be intentional wear those calms so
that it's not she doesn't have to have
these big emphatic dramatic moments to
gain adult attention and don't care and
adult love they're gonna come along the
way and she's gonna push the boundaries
and she's going to find out what's cool
and what's not cool and she's gonna have
to learn social situations and things
like that and that's where the
conversation about privacy is really
important
but all told
it's both and
you're a mother who loves her daughter
and you chose her
and she's not gonna have dad there's
both of those things both those things
are true and she does have a dad
that she's going to meet someday
Maybe
so understand there's gonna be a lot of
complexity there there's gonna be a lot
of stuff that it's gonna be different
than a quote-unquote traditional
childhood and I know it's super hip and
cool to be like there's no such thing
there is such thing and so understand
that she's going to have ups and downs
and hard questions and easy questions
and softballs and Nolan Ryan fastballs
that's just part of parenting
and it's always always comes earlier
than you think
all the questions all the hard ones that
come earlier than you think